I know I'm careful enough as it is you
creepy okay here we go meda meda meda
meda meda Veneman to met me oh hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to alien isolation I've got
a bit of a problem because I'm on my way
running for the rest of my life and
these guys are coming at me hot and
heavy but too bad for them I'm Way
smarter than they ever will be in their
entire life I need to get back I need to
go on my own there's a lot more working
jokes than I thought they were gonna be
also welcome to the first of many
one-hour episodes I did discover this
was this game is 14 hours long and I
appreciate the Adventures of Ripley
junior here but I want to get through it
in a timely manner there's a lot more
games that are coming out I don't want
this to turn into a 28 part series so
I'm gonna make him our long episodes for
all of you to enjoy
hello Dead Guy I already searched
through you so I'm gonna make my way
through as best I can while still
enjoying the environment here I mean I
haven't done a long let's play in a
while I mean the last time I did our
long let's place was probably back when
I did the last of us wasn't it or was it
not that long ago I mean it might have
been but I have no idea oh I could have
used that a long time ago and I've got
those guys coming at my tail I already
picked up the blueprint there I gotta
get back to where I was going before so
I need to pop out here and take a ride
skills made the door then head straight
until I get away from those freaks I
mean this is back to the area where they
weren't bothering me so I don't know if
they're still gonna be after me do I
need to go in any of these weren't these
locked before oh no no this was uh this
was where I went down the stairs to be
able to go back to where I was okay come
on
come on come on there we go now that I'm
done with that I can accelerate
downstairs go through to where I need to
go to reach rendezvous re rendezvous
with my teammates I'm having a bit of
trouble talking are you mad at me oh
these are that doesn't know I don't like
don't look at that oh he's mad at me
okay too bad I'm gonna just go for it
what was fine I don't even know he was
there
holy crap I didn't know the alien was
even doing a thing who I needed on that
computer I'm gonna assume that I could
go without it but there are things in
these rooms oh yeah don't worry your
pretty little head everything's gonna be
just fine
so I'm gonna rewire this see if I can
aid myself in some way I do not yeah
he's back he's going back so I can
rewire this I got a people very close
eye out for alien hello
maybe you talking about lady your
reception has nothing I can turn
lighting off oh yeah the speaker system
would create disturbances for those guys
oh god damn it with you I didn't even
know you were there
how was I supposed to know what the hell
is in the no access gimme gimme gimme
why oh God
it crashed okay so we are back out we've
got to the room they don't know I'm here
I'm still on the lookout for an alien
thankfully I should be able to avoid
contact now I just won't be able to use
that junction box as a relay section
because I'm gonna be calm quiet like a
shadow in the night replace too much of
a badass to be beaten back by you
douches so there's that guy should be oh
of course I go just as he's doing his
thing but I'm okay okay so he doesn't
know I'm there and I should be able to
use this computer terminal and be able
to discover the secrets of what's going
on here I know I know explosion
stabilized it's all bad I know call log
oh what's going on Apollo's going
terribly Android outside Apollo Apollo
Apollo it's killed him
oh that's when everything is going
horribly it's actually corrupted ain't
nothing I can do there so that was a
bunch of uselessness why just something
to keep me there so that I can get dead
by the dunes you gay you what do you got
for me I need to start crafting a bit
more oh I didn't know that I needed that
wait no my revolver was full of bullets
why did it do that
maybe it's come time out all over the
floor okay so now I'm gonna make sure
that everything here is good takeaway
the lighting system calm access air
purification these life line reception I
can't even use reception I guess I might
as well just get the distractions up
with the speaker systems wherever that
may be
okay so the speaker system is going off
over there I don't know if that helps me
it anyway but either way I'm just gonna
move on I'm gonna move on now I'm gonna
back out from this anymore there we go
carry on my way I just got to get back
to over there so that I can get through
that I could just sprint through it
probably wouldn't be that bad with you
I just gotta watch for the aliens he
didn't see anything no no no no oh
that's a thing I am dead it could not
also
I'm out I'm out baby I'm Audi I'm Audi
no aliens no aliens - aliens no aliens
no aliens no aliens
oh no aliens no waterfalls to spit I'm
okay I'm okay
aliens no aliens do aliens no aliens no
alien no no alien Haley Haley no okay
what who's that talking is that
something actually important or do I
need to not worry about that I hope I
didn't miss anything about it because
that may have seemed like it was
important but it also seemed that it was
happening
oh loading screen okay wait click
survivors on the station is just trying
to stay alive don't mess with them and
they won't mess with you that does not
explain the behavior of the people that
I met before
keep moving slowly and carefully that is
good advice I would agree with that one
this is aliens horrible aliens and
robots
Ripley maybe about us but I am a timid
hearted man oh this is where I was this
is exactly where they dict with me oh
I'd vote for anti Ditka tree in this
game although this time I have a gun so
that's different where my bullets go
where they take away my bullets
what is that punishment that's do she is
hell what my bullets had sex game I'm
gonna crash they might have removed
something from me cuz I'm just gonna
assume that there's nothing here but I'm
gonna investigate to see if there's
anything else that is not okay that
little kid she seems kind of weird
who would have a seeks in balloon yes it
is my favorite copy I'm four but I know
about multi-billion dollar take up I
can't even do that voice I was just a
stupid little kid that's what that was
known as me okay so anyway so I need to
find the transit car to be able to get
back to where they are that looks like
it is broken off so I guess I need to go
downstairs to continue this back the way
I came so we're gonna do a little bit of
backtracking and then we're gonna be
back on track if that made any
[Music]
oh all right then
oh god damn it with that thing in the
same I know he was gonna be there how
would I have known not to be stupid and
loud and run all over the place
damn aliens taking all our jobs
messing with Ripley who does he think he
is he or she I don't know might turn
into a queen it's pretty cool moment
though I gotta admit that was pretty
good I had no idea that was gonna be a
giant alien monster after me how was I
supposed to know so I guess I just don't
go up there now huh
am i dragging these things with me noise
Megan at this point
don't call me not dick with me go not
I'm out I'm out baby I'm gonna shut off
the emergency clothes on this duty and
then I'm gonna get out of here emergency
override you ain't come through here
possibly so I go back this way
I remember this area back at the trans
pardon pardon moi
let me save just let me save don't save
when he's right behind me and bout to
kill me do not do that
let me save and everything's gonna be
hunky-dory oh boy no that you Oh God
Vince why the Space Station's have to
have somebody Oh God hello help you
what the hell okay bye didn't make any
sense why okay bye okay I need to go to
the sim Eid transit so I could go to
Solomon's habitation tower but I need to
go to the symud Simon transmits that's
not good
you shouldn't be there what does that
mean what's that even mean I shouldn't
be here I shouldn't be on this station I
think but maybe I'm going to the wrong
place who knows who knows whatever
okay so I think I went to the right
place because I think this one was going
to the Simon tower and it didn't have
the guys with the other thing in it so
I'm assuming I'm right Ripley I'm always
right I'm Ripley jr. sorry
like Bowser jr. except way cooler it's
so good to see you oh okay bye then is
that Ripley yes I'm here
oh you look good how's it going yeah -
she treatment medicals nearby but I
didn't want to leave stop talking like
she's not there see what I can find you
stay with her uh-huh I'll try to repair
the radio booster what if this thanks
Holly
that's a good exception noise right
there that always means something Goods
about to happen I don't know I didn't go
to the Symon Tower or the the not the
Simon tower but the place where those
two twins came from I really wanted to
know what that led to but I felt like I
was in a hurry and I wanted to go to the
right place no no I saw some Sun there
[Applause]
that's some grade a level Ditka tree
going on here
Ripley Junior don't like it too son
space son no screw you for you hello
hello well thank you sure this isn't a
trap but I'll trust them because I'm a
trusting person
oh good another loading screen yay I can
find out how to do stuff so I think
there's gonna be a more involved
crafting system where I can get like
obviously a flamethrowers gonna be a
very big part of this when I get the
flamethrower
things are gonna get pretty badass up in
here now there's not badass enough me
being Ripley jr. and all mm-hmm but
maybe got into the San Cristobal medical
facility how big is this place oh I seem
safe thanks thanks so much what is all
this where am I gonna find the dead
bodies where you've been experimenting
with people this vent are you talking
this vendor another vent it looks like
this might be the van all right here we
go
let us away right okay and I'm supposed
to believe that you're not crazy is that
what I'm supposed to believe good good
cuz I was under the assumption that you
already I'm a very trusting individual
in these horror games also I'm Ripley
dude yep got a good feeling about this
this has all the elements of a good
situation closed spaces a dude on a
radio closing doors behind me and
locking them that's like taking a date
to your house and you just close the
door and goes click I trust you say V
good their arts enough with these save
points do that right now I guess better
than an autosave calathea
Resident Evil or stuff oh is that you
find a doctor my friend needs help
medical supplies from here I'm from
space also Ripley jr. if you didn't know
he looked like he was fine being a big
baby wimping out all over the place okay
so it's manual override so I'm either
supposed to go through that way or I'm
supposed to go through the vent I'll
choose the vent wait does that the vent
that came from the prize event no I came
through the door yeah yeah totally yeah
yeah this is a new vet hope was well why
I choose to go
my favorite walking in pitch blackness
waiting for the darkness monsters to
come kill me this what that was that oh
okay this must be the return passage so
I'm not supposed to go to here
immediately
let's just go goodies goodies oh this
all looks very nice oh hello
thank you what did I get oh I got
although Marley's office is right there
are you kidding me
that douche is in that room he couldn't
walk two steps to Marley's office what a
dick by Hagen this guy's straight up
great a douche I bet he's just a nurse
on staff one of the cleaning people died
etag I think there's a way to read those
ID tags but I can't seem to figure out
how it is and I can't seem to figure I
mean I'm too lazy to stop and figure it
out to use a lever okay open up this oh
this is so complicated to be able to
open these but not all of them have two
steps excuse me
that better be the douche doctor
okay good that's dr. Mann Oh so I say
dr. Mann are you worried about this
alien that's probably gonna kill you
just as you're about to help me cuz
that's usually how these things works
boyfriend I'll be back in like nine
creases there we go
stop staring right at my boobs you're
staring right at my boobs hey eyes up
here I may be hot as hell and totally
handsome also this is raising up all of
my red flags for the knot okay yeah I'm
sure they're all long gone oh boy this
is gonna be so much good I couldn't even
stand how good this is gonna be I know
there's a 3 2 1 countdown on that just
to make me wait and panic in case I need
to go quickly oh cool man a better that
guy better turn into the Oh God
I'm getting flashbacks I just have to be
in the hospital in horror game don't I
that's always where the fun's gonna be
what do we got here camera feed I could
turn his camera off that would be nice
or axis is active then tack says oh I
need venta oh that says door vent door
vent door vent I want it but I'd have to
turn off his camera feed was a good turn
off that oh I'd have to turn off his
camera feed he doesn't need to watch
then taxes thank you
go bye I don't know if what I did was
good wait did that actually commit it
did not commit did it
okay we're good we're good we got the
vent open somewhere I don't exactly know
exactly where but somewhere over here
maybe that's exactly what I needed to do
it is okay
wait why does it get a lot brighter
everywhere when I turn this on that's
weird okay I'm out of here
I'm getting flashbacks from nightmare
house - I don't like that oh whatever
also the glowing green gasps brought out
a good sign where's that go maybe let me
just double
why screw you I'm going in the vents we
oh I get it
okay so the vents will just be for an
emergency escape when I need it good
cool man I hear your camera if you're
still looking at my boobs I'm gonna be
very upset yeah I did it come on come on
come on come on come on I know something
Bad's gonna happen come on they're in
there somewhere all right then
in the computer it couldn't be in the
computer it's so simple low on meds I
know that's the problem Aven he didn't
mention that first I'm gonna guess that
this guy is
I know that is 1702 1702 1702 that's
only moderately creepy 1702 oh I know
what that is oh I know it's like the
weirdest thing I don't know where it is
but I know it's probably here maybe 1702
everybody say with me 1702 help me
remember channel your memory all
cumulatively 1702 mmm 17:02 okay so I
got to go over that way
you live back around 17 Odell Oh God
god that's terrifying
you think it's going that way oh well
you're scary as hell I go on the bed
okay cool bruh you figure out dirt Oh
God
oh it's going the long way around Oh God
in the bed
I was in the room I didn't see it
stop opening the damn door oh-oh-oh-oh
stressful oh oh oh that's bad
those are bad sounds although that dr.
Morley that better be morally that
doesn't sound comforting to me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Oh big palooka oh good golly you are
every bit as terrifying as I had never
hoped you would be
Oh oh god I'm never gonna be able to
hide here Oh God am i safe am i safe -
someone peed my pants I'm just kidding
hello Kay oh never do something they did
all right that was terrifying though
good lord that was like more stressful
than almost anything never reminded me
back in when I originally played oh boy
okay is he coming down this he can't I
closed it
I need the emergency override on that
sumbitch why is he here huh
I need to craft some things got max oh
um P mind I have no idea what that does
but flashbang might be good
last-minute emergency since I've got all
this good stuff
smoke uh-huh yeah uh-huh
noisemaker huh and just because again
I'm gonna do med kit as well just in
case I need it
I'm actually not at full health I could
use that right now yep all better much
better whoa no no no no no no oh
you are the biggest dish
[Music]
how is this better Oh so dead dead did
he just go in the vent oh my god he did
he bogeyed out he boogie down right okay
this is my chance I guess oh I don't
like it how to hide in there I'm crafty
oh okay god damn close okay thank you
okay so looking for dr. Moore wait what
this rooms on dr. Morley why would he be
there he'd be dead wouldn't he I'm just
gonna assume that he'd be dead cuz
otherwise you'd be helping this guy cool
man
No
oh my god words don't tell me he's in
here now
oh god no this is the worst this is
literally the worst why do I have to
deal with this I need to distract him
somehow oh I need to distract why this
is so bad
did I just update my map okay
so I'm gonna try to use the noisemaker
I'm guessing I can throw it oh why oh
bad stuff Oh bad Oh I done goofed harder
than I've ever done goofed in my entire
life
I'm sorry if I'm not very talkative at
the moment I'm in a bit of a stressful
situation I don't know me being quiet is
not gonna help me in this situation at
all but it just makes me feel better so
just bear with me a little bit as I try
to get through this alive so we saved
now we should be good there's no reason
for him to come this way huh there would
be no reason who is that is that doctor
cool man
the doctor oh oh get in the bed
get in the bed Oh God
this is the worst this is exactly
oh oh I did not know that he could come
in there after me oh this is worst Oh
God
Oh okay I still got a long way to go how
am I gonna get over there though
oh he just is the biggest douche he's
always where I don't need him to be baby
I know I'm not private rooms private
rooms baby private rooms emergency
override I'm done Jesus Christmas that
is so uncool oh this looks good
are you the doctor no you're some dead
guy are you the doctor oh my got it I
did it good for me
you just do that cuz I've been the menu
and you're trying to make me paranoid
huh
well too bad for you it's working
[Music]
you know right there I don't know why
the stupid emergency robot it doesn't
fit
I want the supplies in there he's just
hanging around my Dorothy I got to get
back better get back the way I came
he's gonna die let's all play socks
everything about this just sucks
the Bell where to go where it whoa oh
everything about this literally the
worst
[Music]
why
oh crap I just went the wrong way
oh it's better leave me somewhere oh oh
man it's not gonna
No
this guy is literally the biggest douche
I'm gonna throw noise make her the other
way and see if I can get him to go for
it and then loop back around through the
vents
actually throwing for real this time
[Music]
yeah go for that that's interesting huh
that's super weird huh I shouldn't run I
should've just crawled I panicked I
panicked and I didn't need to so
stressful God that is so stressful okay
okay he's not here yet which means I can
go back to oh god I cannot go back the
way I came
apparently let's this'll work this will
work I got the key card it'll work yes
time to go back this way I can go back
this way
give me cool man I'll be fine
I just got gob dub cuz I put the wrong
way also I panicked which is the
stupidest thing as being too slow and
cautious 1702 okay now let's get down to
the dispensary thank you cool man you're
really living up to your family name
better than your mother's main name of
captain do certain senior douche hammer
oh I'm not going that way again screw
that okay which way do I go you need to
go over there I'm gonna go with you I
got the key guard
hello oh you're a handsome devil yeah
I'll collect my things and we can leave
and then you'll be eaten alive because
you deserve it
[Applause]
okay guy what are you deserved but oh
there we go but I can at least go get
them medical supplies go now go now go
now go now no no no no no okay we're
doing great everybody thank you all so
much for supporting me it's not the end
of the episode but thank you anyway
thank you for believing to me find a
trauma kid good good thing they put a
safe thing here that would have been
easy to miss if I hadn't been looking
around and I'm not gonna complain about
that I'm just gonna keep running
screaming like a little baby girl away
from the monster is probably down here
somewhere now please don't tell me
that's my
what what what no no what's that stun
baton whoa hey look at that I'm sure
it's still in working order after being
jammed in the door oh that's handy
so does that guy down here or what oh
boy dead bodies if this was dead space
I'd be more worried I closed that no
it's gonna stay open that's cool dude
let's see what you got so fast - link
all right I need to talk to you I've got
a body up here that's part of the
marshal investigation female late
thirties chest wound
oh no chest burster wound my baby you're
concerned about san cristobal lockdown
has been noted by I assure you and
evacuation allowed to present necessary
and only a temporary measure Gabe I'm
sure that worked out great for everybody
okay
so wait what
what what the hell happened like oh I
guess it had already worked I thought
the game was freezing again my bad okay
so I got a stun a baton but it looks
like it's got only temporary stuff ah I
see so these cool and sunny to uh need
to activate to be able to do stuff with
them
am I gonna freeze them in place Who am I
gonna be able to freeze the monster is
not that I'm gonna be there I'm gonna
fight back yeah okay that didn't do
anything so what am I supposed to do am
I supposed to lure him in there and then
freeze him in there because I can't
activate the cooling system here I must
have already activated it therefore I
can lure him in there with like a
noisemaker and then freeze him that what
I'm supposed to understand here we just
see if I can craft up some more yeah I
got another one how about another one I
hear him I hear him flipping around that
is not cool he's straight above
okay wait there's no reason to be in
here that's just dead bodies so I must I
must
there must be away like Frieza men
that's what I would assume here's the
last one for that
why I just see Giza cooling where did
you even come from you big bag what an
[ __ ] what did I do
cuz I supposed to be able to Sun him
with like the stun baton or something is
that what I was supposed to do
I just always supposed to be very very
careful oh okay I see so the coolant is
so that I can get through the door
because when I activated these it
actually the door actually opened up and
I was able to go through it I'm guess
maybe it uncooled it or something I have
no idea but that's just the way it is
I'm not trying to understand it that's
just all I know so let's just get
through here get done with it
so that we can move on with our life and
be happy forever and ever and ever and
ever and ever so let's be a little
quieter this time preemptively hiding
okay so we're doing okay that door will
be open now and I'll be able to go
through it right no readings not alien
man that's like one of the scariest
monsters I've seen in a horror game it's
like having the dead space invincible
monster there all the time
this place isn't good for my health god
I don't know why but I'm really good I
got a sudden urge that I wanted some
chicken wings I don't know why there's a
dr. lingard senior medical officer
should be able to find out where they're
keeping everything in her office okay
why was your voice all robotic there mr.
robot man you want to tell me something
hmm
okay so now I need to go to the doctor
Lin guards office for information
okey-dokey then and what are those means
exactly so I need to go through that
vent to be able to go where I need to go
I'm guessing anyway I'm gonna try to
make another save because I don't want
to have to do anything over again
because of this stupid maquette refuses
to autosave I don't know even know why
he jumped out and kill me why did it
jump out of killing just cuz I was too
loud the force pacing me I don't know I
don't care it just stresses me
squish squish the lovely sound of dead
bodies underneath my feet
I'm Ripley damn it badass there ain't no
aliens in this vent I'm gonna be just
fine there's a long ladder to climb oh
yeah oh yeah I don't know how you're
gonna insure against all this but hey ow
my legs I broke them I'm seems familiar
a lot of this seems familiar I'm
guessing that when they built this
station a lot of it was modular in terms
of that it was prefabricated so they
didn't need to make it custom every time
and that way they could deploy it easily
build it somewhere else and deploy it
here I'm assuming that was the original
intention so with that being said oh
good thanks for turning on the lights
just what I needed them where am I going
what am i doing where am I going
also I will admit I really appreciate
how this all is very similar in look and
style to the original alien movie oh
it's just so cool and terrifying yeah
I'm actually gonna do this done but I'm
I'm guessing that the stun baton just
takes a lot of batteries when do you use
so I'm not seeing the alien I'm not
hearing them don't know where it would
be I'm still looking for that medical
kit okay this is the showers good old
group showers for everyone to enjoy all
at once I'm going the wrong way when did
I go the wrong way
loop back around I'm pretty sure this
whole facility probably loops around so
I don't think there's an immediate need
to go back plus ago the right on top of
me thing is not okay thank you for the
lights that one I didn't appreciate so
much okay yeah that's what I thought I
thought it all loop around hopefully
there's gonna lead me back to where I
need to go huh
cuz smoking it's definitely the worst to
your problems I don't want to run I
really don't just in case something I do
triggers Hylian to pop out and murder me
oh nice figure
Molotov yes can I make a Molotov
cocktail release gonna get drunk and
they have to forget all this crap that's
been happening to me although I am
Ripley jr. I don't know I'm a badass but
okay
I want you out of San Cristobal now dr.
Morley's the dead guy I got this card
from you know what we've set up in there
and I'm truly sorry for what it means
for the patients who can't be moved but
this is the only way thanks marshal
morally I need you out of medical we've
set up a shop in the habitation Tower
people are fighting over supplies we've
got more injuries coming in that we have
the meds deal with them and my team is
completed to say the least
okay so central wars the code is to 505
remember that everybody to 500 5:00 to
5:05 please help me remember that okay
to 505 medical field can I mix this file
oh crap
oh he's gonna oh I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
I'm dead I'm dead I didn't hide I didn't
hide I'll be the worst in or lose I just
be in my hiding place knowing that
they're on their way screaming oh don't
get me in the closet now and then I'd
survive it there's mine okay so I'm all
done for this episode I've been
recording a while there's some stuff I'm
gonna cut out of my embarrassing
situation but anyway thank you all so
much for watching look forward to more
hour-long episodes of alien isolation
coming out on a regular basis also the
evil within is coming out in a few days
expect that - I'm gonna do both
playthroughs all full playthroughs I'm
committed to it this game is awesome and
frankly that alien is son of a [ __ ] and
is terrifying and I love that I love
that he's actually scary and threatening
in everywhere and omnipresent and won't
leave me alone he's the biggest dick and
I love it so anyway thanks again
everybody for watching and as always I
will
see you in the next
[Music]